on est d'accord un confondre à gauche et
sa droite quand on est chirurgien c'est
embêtant parmi les erreurs médicales qui
ont marqué les esprits il y a celle du
docteur Rolando Sanchez c'est un
chirurgien qui a été jugé en 1995 en
Floride pour avoir amputé le mauvais
pied à un de ses patients de 50 ans pour
se défendre l'homme a expliqué que le
personnel du bloc opératoire avait
préparé le mauvais côté et que le membre
en question était de toute façon
tellement mauvais état qui leur est
sûrement fallu l'amputer un jour ou
l'autre bien sûr le chirurgien a été
suspendu 6 mois le patient lui il était
se faire amputer l'autre pied dans un
autre hôpital et il est décédé 6 ans
plus tard en 2007 à rod Island trois
neurochirurgiens différents ont ouvert
le crâne de leur passion respectifs du
mauvais côté cette fois ils sont rendus
compte de leur erreur avant de commettre
l'irréparable ils ont refermé et ils ont
opéré le bon côté la même année à Los
Angeles un chirurgien a retiré un homme
de 47 ans le testicule droit au lieu du
gauche en 2002 une passion de 46 ans a
subi une ablation des deux seins parce
qu'on lui avait découvert une forme très
agressive de cancer il s'est avéré après
l'opération que sa poitrine était en
fait saine et que ses analyses avaient
été mélangées au labo avec celle d'une
autre patient